yeah so I'm galaxy Kate you can find me
at pretty much anything at galaxy Kate's
a comb I've got a total dumpster fire of
a github repo also at galaxy Kate the
slides for this talk are going to be I'm
gonna go pretty fast so the slides for
this talk are at Galaxy heat comm slash
PDFs I'll show a lot of random apps that
I've made and those are at galaxy
kake-dot-com such apps and you can just
find a bunch of stuff of mine at galaxy
Kade calm so a little bit about me I did
five years on spore in Sim City if you
ever played Spore I did the planets I'm
now six years into a PhD in generative
games and creativity tools of all types
this is at the expressive intelligence
studio at UC set UC Santa Cruz also can
I make a pitch to the conference
organizers to have decaf because I had
caffeinated this morning and we're all
gonna be the worst for it
life is hard for the chemically
sensitive I've done some contracting on
chatbots for the Google home and I
released that open source as the battery
finite state machine platform if any of
y'all saw the really excellent finite
state machine talk clearly this morning
here's another take on it yeah I made
tracery a language for generative BOTS
that currently runs about six thousand
active BOTS which is pretty exciting and
yeah I make generative art BOTS games
art tools and more and I like to teach
other people how to do it so you know
here's a projected head that I've done I
really like the leap motion and leap
motion works I've done procedural dance
generation
here are some generated butterflies this
is a little generated train travel
through Europe game and then this is
just some flowers doing attractive
things yeah so my talk today is about
generative art but like why should I
bring this to a JavaScript conference
it's because a lot of my favorite
generative art pieces both my own and of
others they're interactive there are
things that people can touch and play
with and this is true of a lot of
interesting generative stuff we've we've
all worked with generative art if you've
used a pottery wheel it sort of
mechanically assisted creativity
everything from spire graphs to mitting
can kind of fall into this category you
may have feelings when you see this
if denied we use kid pecks as a kid now
not so many people and what if it was an
American thing but this is like a
generative creativity tool from the very
late 80s that got me started on this but
you can generate pretty much anything
I've made tools for people but I've also
gotten to see a lot of people making
interesting things everything from music
to poetry Industrial Design generative
cocktail recipes so these are the top
one is a poet there's a pottery
generator there's a necklace generator
and a music generator at the bottom but
you can generate things like
tensegrities architecture which is a
form of architecture that couldn't exist
before computers could help us generate
it this is some work by a group called
nervous system and they do generative
dresses and generative necklaces but
these are all interactive prototypes you
can actually change how the necklace
looks before you get it 3d printed and
sent to you you can generate here we go
these are two projects by NASA to do
procedurally generated stuff with
genetic algorithms so if you represent a
radio antenna as a bent piece of metal
you can represent that as a string of
DNA for each radio antenna decide how
well it's going to perform how the
successful ones have lots of babies and
those babies have babies and are judged
and they got their best-ever radio
antenna off of that which looks like a
BET paper clip but it's a very
specifically bent paper clip later on
they use that same method to figure out
how to make a tensegrities ball walk
this is something that no human could
program but it was you know the the ball
that wobbled the best got to have many
babies and then it's babies had babies
and eventually you get something that's
sort of lurches here is a hot rod that
is procedurally generated the chassis is
something that no human would design but
a machine could design it there's tools
like grasshopper 3d that make
interesting pair of metric models you
can kind of 3d print these out in
interesting ways there's a woman named
Bathsheba Grossman who's actually in
Santa Cruz where I am he does
mathematical 3d generated models that
are 3d printed out sometimes quite large
as art pieces you can generate things
with particles so these are strange
attractors which are imaginary swarms of
particles orbiting
strange way some sort of gravitational
body and then you can map their trails
on to 3d geometry and print those out
you can print things using grammars so
the grammars are a way of recursively
sticking objects to other objects so
this is a bot that rolls Thingiverse
which is a 3d printing sight grabs
objects glues them together and then
reuploads them as art the community is
very confused as to whether that's a
good thing or a bad thing I use a lot of
parametric particle based generations so
these are fabric generators that I've
made and these are all in canvas
processing your canvas some of them are
SVG oh I did put little symbols of the
technology that I used for all the ones
that are mine I uploaded these to a
website and you can now buy them as
t-shirts I made a version of this that
generates the fabric patterns and then
prints it out on spoon flour so I'm
currently wearing a Java Script made
skirt one of the swags I have our Java
Script made scarves so yeah there's that
skirt you know for you can of course
generate all sorts of things you can
generate animations games textures all
sorts of things for games so here's one
of the creatures that I made when I
worked on spore but then the the skins
of the creatures you have this 3d model
and you want a texture in some way you
can procedurally unwrap that creature
even if it's a dynamic creature that the
user is made that you've never seen
before you can unwrap it into you this
sort of skin here and then the way we
texture these creatures was actually
with particles where if you imagine you
have a white horse but you want a zebra
you spawn black paintballs on top of it
drop them on top of the horse they stick
to the back of it they roll down getting
smaller and smaller as they go and you
get this sort of stripe pattern but then
if you put like a VW minibus or any sort
of object underneath that and run the
same script you'll get something that
has like zebra stripes even though you
didn't know you wanted the universe
stripes before there's lots of video
games that do procedural content
generation I don't think any of these
are in JavaScript I think they're on
Java or Java like s-- but yeah these all
do procedurally generated levels so you
can kind of if you have a game Java
you can make infinite levels to run
through you can generate stories so this
is minecraft not minecraft sorry Dwarf
Fortress which simulates years and years
of geology sociology ecology to simulate
3000 like 10000 years of dwarvish
history and then it puts you in the
middle of it you can kind of
procedurally excavate as gameplay the
history of this world
you can even generate game rules so this
is work out of I believe NYU that
generates an adventure game dynamically
this one is generated game levels this
is a project called refraction and it
uses procedural generation not just to
design the levels but actually verify
that the levels are unbreakable by
players and then you can design games
themselves this is Yahveh this was also
a genetic algorithm that could design
systems of rules kind of like go where
it's like one piece can move like this
and you capture another piece like this
and the game board looks like this
generated thousands of those generated
the players for them have the players
play the games and then pick the ones
that the players made the most
interesting decisions and then they
produce that game gave it a generative
name and sell it in stores so you can
generate pretty much anything a common
phrase or a common sort of theme with
PCG talks is often oh wow
you can save so much time and money
generating things and you don't have to
hire artists anymore won't that be great
this actually doesn't work that great
you won't get robot artists but instead
you can have art that's made from user
input so you can have like in Spore we
had the users creating these complex
creatures and then we could dynamically
like on a millisecond level skin them
texture that animate them and so the
player just feels like they're making
like magical clay and that's something
that no you can never have an artist
sitting there modeling those you know
millisecond by millisecond a second you
can have art that the computer and the
users make together and you can have art
that just goes on forever and ever and
ever I make a lot of Twitter BOTS and
the Twitter bots if you set a Twitter
bot to posting and the service never
goes down it'll just keep producing
content every n seconds you can even
have an arts
bass that you can explore mathematically
I won't go too far into this but these
bots made scarves are actually made with
roughly a hundred sliders from zero to
one so each one has kind of a different
position of sliders you can imagine that
those are vectors in a tent in a hundred
dimensional space and so if I have this
scarf over here in this scarf over here
I can mathematically say what is this
scarf directly in the middle of those so
you can do interesting like interactions
with that and yeah ways to interact with
a generator there's a lot of different
ways these are a couple of bots that are
running on my actually the sorting hat
bot isn't running on my technology but
these are bots that respond to people
that add them on Twitter so what do you
do with in with a JavaScript generator
well you can have it talk to people so
the one at the bottom left is like my
bad comic generator and if you add it it
will make a little comic and say hey I
made you this done since and Dragons is
an IKEA theme done just in the Dragons
bot and you can tweet at it to have a
little Dungeons and Dragons adventure
there's lots of other really interesting
ways to interact with them everything
from you know I'm going to use my camera
like my can't like my face is input so
the one on the bottom right is Apple the
one on the bottom left is me I'm doing a
particle simulation that kind of draws
these interesting rainbow things this
from interaction is really interesting
because you get people kind of having
this mask that moves and they start to
move their heads and body is in really
interesting way so if you've ever
studied you'd like masks or dance or
costume theory you can get people to
move differently when you generate stuff
around them the one on the top left is
somebody who used tracery to generate
code and then that code ran through a
dynamic Creator of texture and of
animation and sound and they use this to
like do a rave in London
the one in the upper right is like kind
of you have a gesture so the user has
made some sort of gesture and you're
doing something with that gesture so
that one actually is the one in the top
right and bottom left are both running
in JavaScript so the one on the top
right is this is a commission from a 3d
printing company and they wanted
something so it's that
anybody could draw a pennant that could
be 3d printed out so this is basically
like if you take one thing away from
this talk it's that symmetry is like the
MSG of generative art if you have
something bad just put symmetry on it
and suddenly it looks a lot better so
yeah you can generate anything like
geometry sound texture texts recipes you
can use it for any reason you can make
generators so I know a lot of the people
in this room or like at this conference
might be like doing very fairly serious
like div pushing for large enterprise
solutions but you can also just go home
and make a Twitter bot in like five
minutes
you can make something for an arts
festival you can make something to amuse
yourself you can make something that has
a political aim or you can do it for fun
or for fashion but yeah so how do you do
it so second half of this talk let's
talk about making a generator these are
two art BOTS the one on the left is from
the 1700s and it uses cams to
mechanically draw images it's actually
programmable where you can like set the
cogs in certain ways that it like writes
text the one on the right is the
watercolor bought from evil mad
scientist labs where you draw in a
window and then it like has the robot
draw it for you with watercolors so yeah
these are two different things there's a
phrase we used to use on Spore which is
called an artist in a box so you're
making your generator is trying to be
like trying to have the mind of an
artist but you're putting it in a box
and sending see user whether or not you
know on Spore that was actually a shiny
plastic disc but now you know you're
creating something that's gonna run on a
server so the idea is kind of what are
the virtues of your artist this depends
on what you're making this talk is
always hard to give because I as I've
just said you can make pretty much
anything so what does it mean to be a
good architect what does it mean to be a
good storyteller on Twitter what does it
mean to like be good at having a
conversation with somebody so you
basically once you figure out those
constraints about what must and must not
happen and use those to build your
generator I have more about that in this
blog post so you want to build a
generator so yeah how do we actually
build it so I have this thought I've
built probably at least a hundred
various art generators of various
and out of all this I've realized that
generativity is a pipeline so up here
are two fairly odd projects these are
not mine
but they're both out of Design Studios
in Europe the well and they're both
taking brain waves and turning them into
furniture so you start with brain waves
and you're going to furniture and they
take very different paths to this so
what the one on the left you are put
under an MRI scanner or a brain wave
scanner of some sort and told to think
about different kinds of furniture
orange blue solid like not solid round
sharp and it measures your brain waves
and then it like generates a piece of
furniture based on that and they've made
that guy that piece of furniture and he
hates it and so it's art the one on the
right is it actually measures your brain
waves as the waves and then it stacks up
those waves and makes a piece of
furniture out of it but you're supposed
to think of the world weird comfortable
as it does so like two inputs two very
like two inputs to outputs that are the
same but the paths through them are very
different so yeah you have some inputs
and some outputs I made so I make a lot
of free tools and I open sourced them
all this is the deck of cards that I
made to help people think through how to
make generators and they're called the
General Munoz and you can print them out
I have some decks of cards with me but I
actually they're already promised to
people but ask me tomorrow we show you
one and the idea is you have some inputs
so the ones with the blue stripe at the
top are inputs so here's the Kinect and
this is basically the pipeline of data
like you can never turn data into other
data without like putting an algorithm
on it so this was why is it really hard
to design for the leap motion versus
like the DDR pad and a lot of video
games take events and States as their
input so like the sort of little beads
on a string are events and States so a
gamepad will create events in states
like I'm holding down a trigger or I'm
pressing a button and games are really
good at taking those as inputs so if I
have a gamepad I can make a game no
problem if I have a like rock band
guitar that's producing events in States
and oh boy I can totally make a game out
of that if I have a Kinect it's actually
like a mesh of vertices so like there's
a bunch of vertices sort of floating in
space well how am I going to convert
those into you button presses that my
videogame needs well you kind of have to
have the detect gestures one so it's
like okay I'm gonna turn this set of
vector data into press button a and I'm
gonna turn this set of vector data into
press button maybe I wanted to do a
project that had kind of a different
approach to that so this is a project I
did called idle hands for an Arts
Festival
this takes sleep motion data which is
vector data and then runs a Voronoi
algorithm on it which takes vector data
and turns it into triangles and that was
pretty much all I did this had my best
ever review which was from somebody who
was fairly chemically altered he thought
his hands were stuck in the screen not
in a bad way just in a way that he had
to like sit with for a while so this is
kind of the general knows these are two
different ways of documented on Jenna
Rama knows but yeah like basically you
get the particle data you run it for one
hour you diagram you triangulate the
regions you draw the polygons and you
projected on a screen so this is kind of
ways to think of how data wants to
transform into other data so yeah it's
kind of a pipeline but I want to show
you the Lego bricks that you're going to
use in the pipeline this is basically
the like tools you can use section if
you've ever wanted to generate something
and these are kind of the big ones that
they fall into
so there's grammars which is one of my
favorites this is like you're making
things out of other things I have this
language called tracery that I made
which is basically like writing in JSON
these recruits recursive recipes because
it's JSON which is fairly safe somebody
actually made a node bot or like a node
service that host these JSON files and
post them to Twitter periodically this
is the one that's currently running six
thousand BOTS this is one the earliest
ones is hipster cocktails and you can
kind of see the recipe for making a
hipster cocktail you know it's got a
name it's got you know combine some
liquid with some other liquid put in
something and maybe make like yeah
somebody also figured out that because
it's generated text
what's a kind of recursive text
SVG HTML and so because I like fun
JavaScript things I just been learning
JavaScript at that point and my online
editor had used HTML in jQuery to fill
in my divs instead of txt text and so
everything you put in would be parsed as
actual HTML and so if somebody you
figured out that you could do SVG with
that and then suddenly we had art bots
so yeah these are a couple of things
that I've made with tracery and SVG
these are some art generators spaceship
generators I made a taiko ytt outfit
generator because he wears really out
awesome outfits you can also do tiles
which is the idea that like if I have
something that is split up into even
sections and I can kind of put things
into this section if you've ever played
Settlers of Catan where you have like
this grid and you're putting tiles
randomly on it that's kind of using tile
based things but Diablo was one of the
first games that kind of use this for
map generation and you can totally not
see that those are Maps up there but
there are maps that somebody is
documented this is one of the oldest
ones this is an example of using tile
based music so this is not only
generation generativity from 1700 it's
IP infringement from the 1700s this is
not actually by Mozart but it the
publisher said it was and this is called
vais music and so you roll some dice and
then you pick out the measure and you
like put a bunch of measures together so
it's like I mean if music is kind of a
grid of measures then you can just like
paste in the tiles of new measures
parametric is another one that I use a
lot this is basically the idea that you
have a lot of sliders as seen up above
so this is a flower generator that uses
32 different sliders and I can do all
sorts of fun stuff like I can actually
control this with music or I can control
it with hand gestures or I can have the
the user navigate it in different ways
so the one at the bottom is you're just
picking the flower that you like the
best and you're sort of procedurally
evolving them there's kind of a whole
class of ones that are like geometric
transformations this is something like
you've got a curve you play okay cool so
the user has made some sort of gesture
either with your hand or with a mouth
mouth mouth or with whatever input
you've got
you could do it with a mouth that would
be interesting and then you're gonna
take that curve and do something
interesting along it so a lot of these
techniques are kind of like you have
some input I want you to exaggerate and
riff on that input in some way so the
one at the top is IO brush you can use a
webcam to sort of slurp up images and
then you can paint them along a curve
that's about maybe 12 years old by now
but at the bottom is tilt brush which
you're drawing curves in 3d and then
they've got all sorts of like a whole
library of interesting stuff that you
can do along that curve like glitter
effects and particle effects and
animations and like sort of different
stuff here a couple of works that I've
done in curves these the one at the top
is how I generated any scarves using
these curves and making interesting SVG
along them the one at the bottom is
actually a lick motion thing where you
can draw with your hands and then it
makes kind of interesting living curves
out of it yeah let's see oh here we go
here's one that like takes curves and
draws floral patterns along am i I
really don't know what I'm doing with a
lot of these like I just kind of
decorate the curves and then figure out
an interesting form of interaction for
them I don't know how to interact with
the flowers yet but here's a really good
example of using that this is actually a
gallery piece come on play here we go
this is called the treachery of
sanctuary by Chris milk and you would
have these sort of monolithic mirror
projections and as you extend your arm
it takes the geometry of your arm and
extends it out into wings so this is
taking like a small scrap of geometry
and making it something bigger and more
expressive this is great cuz like you
don't need to be taught how to do this
it's just continuously like shifting
what your arm means distribution this is
a really common one this is just like I
have a bunch of stuff and I want to
scatter it around so you can think of
how things are scattered in nature so
like go outside and look at the lava
fields and like see how rocks are
clustered around other rocks and then
the moss is clustered around those there
are really interesting things to do with
generativity in distribution in like
alternate reality games so if you have
something like Pokemon go how are the
monsters scattered around the world like
what logics are you
using for that you could have what they
do which is like where there's more foot
traffic we're gonna scatter more
monsters you could say like in every
piece of land that was taken by Native
them taken from Native Americans like
before 1900 we're going to put the
monsters there and you're going to
actually like see where the landscape
was defined so you can like make
different choices about distribution you
know where do you want to put things in
your world is it where there's more
pollution less pollution more people
less people more to car traffic less car
traffic particles in simulation I do a
lot of stuff with particles just because
it's like it's my personal favorite tool
so the the body's up there actually
particles that are being pushed around
by the music so imagine like you created
dance because you have a little sentient
Tribble on your wrist and every time it
hears a bass beat it does that and like
you'd do another one like and then you
would apply those to your hips so you
can kind of like create little dances
out of that the one on the bottom left
is Boyd's flocking which is like how you
create flocks of things that stay
together what can you do with that well
you can leave trails behind it so these
are actually little particles that are
zooming around with their little physics
pushes and I'm leaving trade trails
behind them and that creates these kind
of interesting 3d flowers I really
wanted to mention machine learning just
because like what do you do with machine
learning well it's another part of the
pipeline so remember how I talked about
we're turning curves into other things
this is you tell the user to draw a
couple of curves and then you are going
to run a little machine learning thing
on it that for every pixel tries to make
it look as much like a cat as possible
and just kind of iterative like for this
patch of pixels how do I like sort of
wobble the pixels such that they look as
much like a cat as possible so this is
like procedural cat wobbling to generate
that sort of thing you can use it for
more serious stuff this is Alex Hoffman
dard who's got a start-up now which is
trying to do artistic stuff with
interactive machine learning where you
can like color in sort of mspaint style
and then it will just like it with the
cats waggle the pixels until it looks as
much like it thinks Monet should look so
yeah like a little bit I wanted to talk
a little bit at least about JavaScript
because it's got a lot of features that
are really well suited for generativity
I used to do processing
then our about 2012 I got contracted to
teach a class in JavaScript so then I
had to learn JavaScript and then I got
into processing yes and that was just a
huge life changer because I love the
functional programming stuff so you can
like new maps and filters and reduces so
it's all like it's a pipeline sort of
thing actually works with kind of
different options in in JavaScript where
like you know you might have a user
gesture and you're gonna turn that into
curves and then you're going to turn
those curves into like different stamped
shapes or styled curves in some way you
might have particles doing like a
particle physics simulation you can turn
those into curves or into stamped shapes
any one of those might turn into u3 dot
J's models or they might turn it through
like p5 canvas stuff or SVG you might
take that p5 canvas thing and turn it
into a PNG that you're using in 3GS so
here's like some physics sim that's
pushing particles around and turning
them into curves
here's physics that are like
procedurally on kinking the curves that
the particles are making and then here's
something where this project I did a 3GS
butterfly simulator and I'm using
process I'm using particles and
processing to draw the wings that I'm
rendering to canvas that I'm sending
over to 3GS as my textures so you can
really set up these wild chains there's
a whole bunch of different generative
libraries everything from dance rjs to
take music and give you numbers and if
you have those numbers what are you
gonna do with those numbers
I don't know generate something Voronoi
I've made these like libraries called
tracery and battery but you know you've
got s e-g canvas 3GS processing all
different ways to output art and then I
really like how you can get different
interfaces so you can make stuff with
Twitter data you can make stuff with big
data ap is something that I didn't
mention here is like visualization is a
form of generative art you are taking
some data you are running some
interesting tools on it pop you know
grammars or parameters or whatever and
you're getting some interesting art out
of it
I like the leap motion even though it's
kind of on the downturn now it's like
unpopular because nobody could figure
out what to do with it
you can do mouse gestures you can do 3d
printing API
I don't know what people are gonna do
with augmented reality but if you've got
like I'm gonna scan this room and do
some augmented reality and stuff in it
I'm gonna need generative art to figure
out like what do I do with the table
what do I do with the table that's got
like that arrangement of glasses on it
you know if I wanted to wait a
generative garden over this entire thing
there are processes I just showed you
that I could use to simulate interesting
garden stuff but I could never have an
artist sit here and like dynamically
figure out what everything is going to
be on every table and then 3d printing
api's which are fun but spoon flower
which is the fabric printing one that I
did no longer has a direct API you can
still upload stuff to it but like you
can't have it dynamically respond to
users actions oh yeah and that's the kid
using my idle hands thing so yeah in
conclusion javascript has a lot of good
features it has libraries plays well
with unusual interfaces you can make
something that makes something it's not
hard to build these things what are the
swags that I brought with me is I made a
bot and my bot makes art buttons or
sorry stickers so if you've ever made an
art bot or something that makes what you
consider art come up to me and you can
totally get one of those stickers if you
haven't come up to me later and I will
show you how to use tracery and in five
minutes you will have an art bot and
then a sticker so yeah
you